NEED.
THAT’S WHAT THE BOTTOM LINE,
THAT’S WHAT IT COMES DOWN.
TO SAY LET’S BRING IN
CONGRESSMAN DOUG COLLINS RANKING
MEMBER FROM THE U.S. COMMITTEE.
OFF KWAOERPBG FOR A QUARANTINING
A HALF.
>> I’M HERE BRIGHT AND EARLY
LISTENS TO THE GOOD NEWS THAT
THE BILL DID GET PASSED AND
LOOKING FORWARD FOR THAT RELIEF
TO GET TO PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
DESK.
AINSLEY: I WAS READING SOME OF
THESE THINGS THAT WAS IN
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S.
349 BILLION IN LOANS.
I LOVE.
THIS THIS JUST SHOWS HOW GREAT
AMERICA IS MONEY SPENT ON RENT,
PAYROLL OR UTILITIES IS
CONSIDERED A GRANT.
AND THOSE SMALL BUSINESSES DON’T
HAVE TO PAY IT BACK.
DO YOU KNOW MUCH ABOUT THIS?
>> YEAH.
THAT’S WHAT WE HAVE BEEN DOING.
I HAVE BEEN GOING OVER THIS BILL
FOR THE LAST FEW DAYS.
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
WHEN WE FIRST PUT THIS BILL OUT
A WEEK OR SO AGO.
NUMBER ONE OUR HEALTHCARE WAS
TAKEN CARE OF.
OUR FOLKS AND OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS WERE A PART OF THAT
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
SMALL BUSINESSES AND PEOPLE.
THAT’S WHAT THE FOCUS OF THE
PRESIDENT’S HAS BEEN AND THAT’S
WHAT THE FOCUS OF THE
REPUBLICANS HAS BEEN.
GET THE RELIEF TO PEOPLE SO
NUMBER ONE BUSINESSES CAN KEEP
PEOPLE EMPLOYED.
WE DON’T HAVE TO HAVE TO LAY
THEM OFF AND SHUT THEIR BUSINESS
DOWN.
WE WANT TO GIVE THEM THE RELIEF
THEY NEED.
KEEP THEM EMPLOYED AND OFF THE
UNEMPLOYMENT ROLES THEN WE CAN
SEE OUR ECONOMY COME BACK
QUICKER AND THAT’S WHAT THAT IS
FOR.
STEVE: THAT’S RIGHT IT.
CANNOT COME SOON ENOUGH.
YESTERDAY IT WAS ANNOUNCED THAT
APPARENTLY THE CHEESECAKE
FACTORY THAT GREAT BIG
RESTAURANT THAT EVERYBODY LOVES
TO GO TO, THEY ANNOUNCED THROUGH
THEIR CEO APPARENTLY YESTERDAY.
THAT APPARENTLY THEY CANNOT PAY
THEIR RENT COME APRIL 1st.
SO, THIS PARTICULAR BILL, WHICH
THE HOUSE, WHICH YOU ARE A
MEMBER OF, CONGRESSMAN, WITH L.
VOTE ON IT SOUNDS LIKE TOMORROW
MORNING.
IT HAS PASSED THE SENATE.
HERE’S THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
TALKING ABOUT POISON PILLS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT.
WATCH.
>> IF WE DON’T HAVE UNANIMOUS
CONSENT, MY TWO OPTIONS WITH MY
MEMBERS IS TO CALL THEM BACK TO
VOTE TO AMEND THIS BILL OR TO
PASS OUR OWN BILL AND GO TO
CONFERENCE WITH THAT THE EASIEST
WAY TO DO IT IS FOR US TO
COME -- PUT ASIDE SOME OF OUR
CONCERNS FOR ANOTHER DAY AND GET
THIS DONE.
YOU CAN SUPPORT A BILL BECAUSE
IF IT DOESN’T DO ENOUGH THAT YOU
WANT TO DO BUT THAT’S WHAT YOU
CAN GET, BUT IF IT HAS POISON
PILLS IN IT, THEN -- AND THEY
KNOW CERTAIN THINGS ARE POISON
PILLS.
THEN THEY DON’T WANT UNANIMOUS
CONSENT.
THEY JUST WANT AN IDEOLOGICAL
STATEMENT.
STEVE: SO, CONGRESSMAN, THAT WAS
A COUPLE OF DAYS AGO WHERE NANCY
PELOSI WAS TALKING ABOUT HOW YOU
WOULD VOTE ON IT.
IT SOUNDS LIKE THEY WOULD LIKE
TO DO IT VIA UNANIMOUS CONSENT;
HOWEVER, AOC HAS ALREADY
SUGGESTED SHE MIGHT HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH IT.
IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO ALL GO BACK IN SOME
FASHION TO ACTUALLY DO SOME
VOTING IN PERSON, RIGHT?
>> WELL, THAT’S WHAT IT IS
LOOKING LIKE RIGHT NOW.
THERE IS STILL A LOT OF QUESTION
ABOUT THAT AS FAR AS -- WOULD
NOT BE UNANIMOUS CONSENT A VOICE
VOTE AND PEOPLE CAN HAVE DEBATE
AND PUT IN THE RECORD OR VOICE
THEIR CONCERNS OR HOW THEY WANT
TO DO IT OR HAVE IT PUT INTO THE
RECORD HOW THEY WOULD HAVE VOTED
IF THEY COULD HAVE BEEN THERE
SOME AREAS WHERE PEOPLE CANNOT
ATTEND.
IT IS SORT OF INTERESTING OVER
THE LAST FEW DAYS FOR NANCY
PELOSI THE SPEAKER PUTTING
IDEOLOGICAL PILLS IN THERE WHEN
THEY TRIED TO PUT IN THE GREEN
NEW DEAL.
THEY TRIED TO PUT IN A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT WE KNEW
WAS NOT GOING TO BE PART OF THIS
BUT THEY KNEW THIS BILL WAS
GOING TO HAVE TO PASS BUT THEY
TRIED TO -- I’M GLAD TO SEE SHE
WAS OVERCOME THAT SO THIS BILL
CAN GET TO THE PRESIDENT’S DESK.
BRIAN: SHE IS TALKING ABOUT
HERSELF POISON PILLS.
SHE RODE INTO TOWN WITH TWO
PAGES OF POISON PILLS.
SHE EVEN GOT SOME OF THEM IN
THIS THING.
FOR HER TO SAY THAT WITH A
STRAIGHT FACE WITHOUT A LAUGH
TRACK IS COMICAL.
THE BIG QUESTION IS WILL STO*EUR
AND OTHERS KEVIN MCCARTHY SAY I
NEED YOU BACK IN WASHINGTON OR
WILL YOU BE ALLOWED TO DO A
VOICE VOTE ON YOUR PHONE OR SOME
WAY A SECURE LINE?
HOW DO YOU SEE THIS GOING?
>> WE’RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
VOICE VOTE ON THE PHONE THAT’S
NOT ALLOWED.
VOICE VOTE WILL OCCUR CALL THE
VOTE YEA AND NAY AND PEOPLE WILL
BE ABLE TO VOICE THAT VOTE.
DEBATE TIME COME AND PUT A
STATEMENT IN THE RECORD.
NOW, IF SOMEONE CALLS FOR A
RECORDED VOTE.
THEN WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THAT ISSUE AS WELL.
SOMEONE CAN ALWAYS CALL FOR A
RECORD VOTE WHICH MEANS EVERY
INDIVIDUAL WOULD HAVE TO VOTE ON
THEIR OWN.
WE DO NOT HAVE THE PROCESSES SET
UP FOR PROXY VOTE OR FOR A
REMOTE VOTING AND THAT’S
SOMETHING THAT’S BEEN TALKED
ABOUT A LOT.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU HAVE MEMBERS
IN NEW YORK AND OTHER PLACES WHO
CAN’T LEAVE FROM WHERE THEY ARE
ANYWAY.
AGAIN, THIS IS GOING TO BE AN
INTERESTING TIME OVER THE NEXT
FEW HOURS TO FIND OUT EXACTLY
HOW THEY WANT TO DO THIS.
BRIAN: AND JUST TO FLOW UP
REAL QUICK, CONGRESSMAN, ON
THAT.
THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE THE LAST
TIME YOU ARE ASKED TO VOTE.
YOU GUYS HAVE TO COME UP WITH A
SYSTEM.
THERE IS GOING TO BE A FOURTH
BILL, FIFTH BILL AND OTHER
THINGS TO BE DONE BUT MIGHT BE
TOO DANGEROUS FOR YOU TO GO BACK
TO WASHINGTON.
YOU GUYS HAVE GOT TO COME UP
WITH SOMETHING THAT’S BETTER
THAN THE IOWA APP.
>> YOU BETTER BELIEVE IT.
THAT’S ONE OF THE THINGS WE HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT A LOT.
THERE ARE THINGS WE CAN DO.
THERE IS PROXY VOTING.
THERE IS ALSO SOME OTHER WAYS
THAT WEEKEND ACTUALLY DO THIS.
MANY OF US HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THAT.
LEADER MCCARTHY HAS BEEN VERY
ENGAGED IN.
THIS I KNOW THE OTHERS AS WELL.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT THIS AS WE GO
FORWARD.
MY HOPE IS AFTER THIS BILL LET’S
TAKE A PAUSE AND SEE WHAT THIS
IS DOING.
LIKE THE 15 DAYS THE PRESIDENT
ASKED FOR.
THIS IS GOING TO GET TO THE
PEOPLE WHO IS GOING TO NEED IT
MOST.
OUR BUSINESSES, OUR PEOPLE AND
HOSPITALS.
SEE WHERE WE NEED TO GO NEXT.
WEAVE DON’T NEED PELOSI AND
SCHUMER NEED TO RUSH INTO
ANOTHER SPENDING BILL.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THIS IS
WORKING AND TARGETED LIKE THE
PRESIDENT AND SECRETARY MNUCHIN
WANTED AND THAT’S WHAT WE NEED
TO DO FIRST.
AINSLEY: MAYBE YOU WOULD BE ABLE
TO USE ZOOM OR SKYPE TO VOTE.
HOPEFULLY NAVIGATE THAT AS WE
GET CLOSER TO THE NEXT VOTE.
LET’S TALK ABOUT CORONAVIRUS IN
YOUR STATE IN GEORGIA.
WE ARE SEEING A SUDDEN SPIKE
THERE 1387 CASES, 47 DEATHS.
HOW IS GEORGIA DOING, SIR?
>> GEORGIA IS DOING AS GOOD AS
WE CAN RIGHT NOW.
THE GOVERNOR IS TAKING
PRECAUTIONARY STEPPING.
HE IS DOING, I BELIEVE, TO MAKE
SURE EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS DOWN
HERE WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN.
HE CLOSED OUR BARS AND
RESTAURANTS MAKING SURE WE ARE
KEEPING IN TRACK WITH WHAT THE
FEDERAL GUIDELINES ARE WE ARE
SEEING IT LIKE EVERYWHERE ELSE.
CERTAIN HOT SPOTS SEEM TO POP
UP.
OVER 1300, 470 OR OVER 400
HOSPITALIZED RIGHT NOW.
RIGHT NOW THE CURVE SEEMS TO BE
SLOWING LIKE WE HAVE SEEN.
HOPEFULLY THAT WILL CONTINUE.
EVERYBODY IS TAKING IT
SERIOUSLY.
ONE OF THE ISSUES WE ARE DEALING
WITH HERE IS OF COURSE BECOMING
HARVEST SEASON MAKING SURE OUR
WORKERS ARE ABLE TO GET FOOD
SUPPLY OUT AND TRUCK DRIVERS
ABLE TO GET THAT OUT TO THE
STORES.
GEORGIA IS COPING LIKE THE REST.
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE IT AND SEE
THIS THROUGH.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE ARE
ALL IN THIS TOGETHER AND WE NEED
TO TAKE CARE OF EACH OTHER
DURING THIS TIME AS WELL.
STEVE: THIS IS SO WELL-PUT.
WE HAVE GOT TO TAKE CARE OF EACH
OTHER.
THAT HAS BROUGHT US ALL
TOGETHER.
AT THE SAME TIME, CONGRESSMAN,
AND YOU ARE ON THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE, IT SOUNDS LIKE THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS LOOKING
AT PEOPLE WHO PURPOSEFULLY
INFECT OTHERS.
AND SO HERE’S A QUOTE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
CORONAVIRUS APPEARS TO MEET THE
STAT TORISTATUTORY DEFINITION OF
BIOLOGICAL AGENT.
THREATS OR ATTEMPTS TO USE
COVID-19 AS A WEAPON AGAINST
AMERICANS WILL NOT BE TOLL
TOLERATED.
IT SOUNDS LIKE PEOPLE COULD
ACTUALLY BE CHARGED IF THEY
INFECT OTHERS KNOWINGLY,
CONGRESSMAN.
>> I THINK IT’S A GREAT TO SEE
THE WHOLE OF GOVERNMENT APPROACH
GOING ON RIGHT.
>> NOW THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
MAKING IT VERY CLEAR IF YOU WANT
TO DO SOMETHING OR INFLICT HARM
OR PSYCHOLOGICAL HARM OR EVEN
PHYSICAL HARM ON SOMEONE WITH
THIS VIRUS, THAT THEY ARE GOING
TO BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
I HAVE HEARD REPORTS OF PEOPLE
JOKINGLY SAYING THAT THEY’RE
COUGHING ON PEOPLE AND I HAVE
THE VIRUS AND THEY DON’T.
THAT CAUSES A FEAR RIGHT NOW
THAT IS UNWARRANTED.
I THINK THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IS MAKING IT VERY CLEAR.
IF YOU WANT TO DO SOMETHING LIKE
THIS THAT HURTS THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, YOU’RE GOING TO BE IN
TROUBLE.
BRIAN: CONGRESSMAN, THE OTHER
BIG STORY ACTUALLY TO DISCUSS
THROUGHOUT THIS THREE HOURS AND
THROUGHOUT THE DAY THE PRESIDENT
REALLY ITCHING TO LIFT THE
ECONOMIC SANCTIONS AND THE DEAD
LOCK ON THE ECONOMY IN SECTIONS
THAT DON’T BE SEVERELY INFECTED.
HAS THERE BEEN LEGITIMATE
BIPARTISAN TALK ABOUT HOW TO
START OPENING UP THE ECONOMY
AGAIN?
>> I THINK THE BIGGEST STARTING
UP OF OPENING THE ECONOMY IS
GETTING THIS BILL AND GETTING
RELIEF AID TO THE FOLKS WHO NEED
IT TP*EUFRPLTS THE PRESIDENT HAS
DONE A GREAT JOB OF DOING A TWO
PRONGED APPROACH.
NUMBER ONE, LOOKING OUT FOR THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF AMERICANS
MAKING SURE WE TAKE KYRIE OF
SOCIAL DISTANCING DOING THE
THINGS TO KEEP THE SPREAD DOWN.
AT THE SAME TIME, LOOKING WITH
AN EYE KNOWING WE ARE GOING TO
COME OUT OF THIS AND THE ECONOMY
NEEDS TO BE IN A SHAPE WHERE WE
CAN RECOVER AND RECOVER QUICKLY.
THIS IS EXACTLY CONVERSATIONS
BEING HAD.
THIS BILL IS THE FIRST STEP
ALONG WITH THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
PRECAUTIONS BEING PUT IN BY THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS TEAM.
BRIAN: ALL RIGHT, CONGRESSMAN.
THANK YOU.
AINSLEY: YEAH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US.
WE APPRECIATE IT.